the wikipedia entry for the loudly
hypothesis was actually taken down
right it was it was fact-checked out of
existence by what turns out to be
a small band of motivated activists okay
so
um you you i guess had this pulled
pulled up uh so this is
there was for a brief time a covid19 lab
leak hypothesis
notice the phrasing not lab leak theory
lab leak hypothesis page
that very responsibly chronicled the
evidence for the lab leak hypothesis
and it was taken down
as a result of an incessant
and very powerful campaign by a small
number of people
behind the scenes there is some evidence
that that campaign
involved uh what would be called a water
army
a water army being a chinese phenomenon
in which people are hired to make social
media posts
that sway opinion so this is a known
phenomenon
and there is i mean i i assume that
happens all the time i've never heard
the term water army before that i think
it does happen all the time and i think
water army
applies specifically to the chinese
version of it which has been
large scale you know the chinese have
taken a very aggressive
stance with respect to what is tolerated
on the internet and there is a
battle over uh various platforms in
which chinese
uh people exchange information
under the radar but in any case i guess
i'm sorry
like one thing that i do not understand
about this conversation
is um it's you know and i think i said
this on
on the last episode you know like it's
easy to to try to smear those of us who
are talking about it as if it's because
we're anti-chinese you know we're
cynophobic
and i think actually if this does turn
out to have been a leak
as a result of gain of function research
um in
at this lab in wuhan um that
points the finger in if you go back
just a little bit more more at american
science and scientists and
the nih and such than it does to china
and
not to say that um you know china
if if this is true would not have been
involved in a cover-up in all of this
but
the idea that this is um that this would
make
china look bad it would look
it would make a lot of virologists look
bad
and the whole program of gain of
function research and serial passaging
look
bad and potentially
it would reveal to us the downstream
effects of the moratorium that the obama
administration put in place precisely
because of the risks of this research
and the mistake presumably that it was
for the trump administration to raise
the moratorium like you know it just it
makes a whole lot of people look bad and
i don't feel like china is
really special in that list well it's
becoming special because it is behaving
in an obstructionist
fashion with respect to the
investigation of the cyprus but the who
i mean the who's giving them complete
covert
right i agree this does not start out in
fact i've got
i've got a piece of an interview here to
share as you wanted me too
okay on that topic um well let's uh
let's finish this out though okay
um so we've got
let's let's take your challenge here
and just notice in a world in which we
are going to decide that scientific
consensus
is the arbiter of what is a fact then
let's map
the lab leak hypothesis question onto it
and note the very
um dangerous circumstance we find
ourselves in
either sarsko v2 is an escapee
from the lab or it isn't
if it is an escapee from from the lab in
wuhan
then it suggests something about the
danger of
escapes that you can effectively crash
the world economy
and you know kill millions of people um
by accident because you know maybe you
were doing
what you thought was honorable research
but that research
you know the cost benefit analysis
wasn't what you thought it was
either that's true or
it did come from nature if it came from
nature these things can potentially hop
out at any time
and crash the world economy and kill
millions of people etc etc and so the
point is
either the implication is either
we shouldn't have been doing this
research because the danger was way too
big or
we should have been doing it sooner and
bigger and more labs and all of that
stuff so
the point is the decision it's not just
a conflict of interest it's like
you know thrive or die it's not just
like just continue to eke out a
fragile existence or go down screaming
it's like
you're going to either become the most
important
types of researchers in the world right
or you are going to be recognized
as having done the research that helped
you know spur the world into a global
pandemic and economic collapse
those who created um this research
program and this was an international
effort those who created it
are either the heroes or the villains of
this story yeah right and
the idea that we are now going to fight
that out on the basis of well if it's a
consensus and it's in wikipedia
then it's a fact and everything else
can't be discussed on social media well
what's going on
you know at wikipedia when you look
behind the scenes you have people
openly discussing the best tactics
for sustaining the attack that is to say
you know berating people to the point
that they ultimately give up
is being discussed as a tactic in the
editing
part of wikipedia so the point is this
doesn't have anything to do with facts
this has to do with people who want that
that entry
down for their own reasons whatever they
may be shaping what the world takes to
be
a factual reference now the fact is i
use wikipedia all the time
it does there's certain kinds of things
that you can you know
go in there you know if you want to look
up uh you know the
chemical constituents of a particular
you know molecule is a pretty good
chance you can find it in there and the
chances that that's subject to some sort
of political
wrangling are pretty low right um but
there are other things in which there's
a lot at stake in which you just can't
rely on it as a factual reference and
there's no mechanism hence
we're stuck with what we call
misinformation and the thing that scares
me
most of all is that the ratio
of misinformation to high quality
heterodox information
is probably a thousand to one on a good
day
right the high quality heterodox
information
is buried in a sea of garbage
and if you get people to focus on the
sea of garbage and you say wouldn't you
like to be
free of this thousand pieces
of bad information wouldn't the world be
better off without them well maybe it
would be but you can't get rid of them
without
getting rid of the secret sauce which is
the one in a thousand pieces that you
absolutely
need to chase down and doesn't have the
defense of hey this is a fact and we all
agree on
[Music]
you